JP: I am not expecting to make it out alive, I'll be honest.
Dlive: I thought you were gonna say I'm not expecting to make out with anybody.
(laughter)
Mark: I don't expect it to happen. How could it? Come on guys.
Entoan: I know we like to rub each other, but come on.
Dlive: That's exactly where I thought that was going.
Wade: I hope the killer gets me once, 'cause I wanna be rubbed.
Mark: Hey, rubbing is, like- rubbing's fine but making out, god you pervert. What do you think, you sicko?
JP: I- no, I did not- that was not said. I would like an instant replay of what I truly said
Mark: Yeah (x2)
Dlive: Maybe you tried to save it. You tried to save it.
JP: I- I didn't try to save it! I didn't say it!
Wade: Oh hey, who's this? You wanna make out?
Entoan: Oh, we can?
Mark: (laugh) HEY HEY NO MAKING OUT IN MY FOREST!
Mark: MY LOG AND CAMP DOESN'T ALLOW ANY MAKING OUT
Wade: Sorry!
Wade: That's-That's why the killer is after us. We're making out in his forest
JP: Alright, this is- this is not a good idea.
Mark: (laughs) Th-That's the essence of all these horror movies is is kids tryin' to be-
Wade: Oh!
Wade: (making out noises)
Mark: No (x8) none of that (x3) c'mon (x3)
Wade: (continues making make out sounds)
Mark: HEY (x7)!
Dlive: Whoa
Mark: You better not be making out
Wade: We'll leave your generators alone. Just let us get that tongue action
Mark: (starts chainsaw and mimics sound)
Mark: You better not be making out in my woods
JP: OH! Why?!
Mark: (still making chainsaw noises)
Mark: Someone making out over here?
(make out sounds and laughing) No! Nope! (x3)
Mark: I thought I heard someone makin' out over here
Entoan: Right over there!
Mark: Huh?
Entoan: But in the other corner, yes
Mark: HUH?! OH GOD. Well, that was quick
Wade: Yeah. Well, when I said we were making out, I might've been lying
Mark: Oh, I see
JP: Well, he was making out with the generator though
JP: He wasn't lying about that
Mark: So now you're rubbing on each other is the thing
Wade: You stick your tongue in the generator
Dlive: Whoa, are you into that?
Entoan: We were touching that generator
Dlive: Are you into that kind of stuff?
Mark:  Oh man. You guys, oh- ooh
Mark: Is I detect a make out session going on over here? Huh?!
Wade: (yells)
Mark: (chainsaw noises)
JP: I hear some bad things!
Wade: Oh no! He came the other way! Oh no!
Mark: (excited chainsaw noises)
Dlive: He said no making out
Mark: NO MAKIN' OUT IN MY WOODS, BOY
JP: Oh! Ok, that's a good- this is good
Wade: OH!
Mark: BWAH!
Wade: (shrieks and laughs)
Mark: (laughs)
JP: Wade! You gotta stay alive!!
Wade: I'm going to!
Dlive: Stay alive, Wade
Dlive: Just remember, no making out and you'll survive
Mark: That outta teach you young kids to make out in my woods (chainsaw noises)
Mark: (laughs) Hello. Hi.
Wade: (yells)
Mark: How are you doing?
(laughter)
JP: Uh... Wade...?
Mark: Where'd you go? Did I get'cha?
Dlive & Entoan: Wade (x2)
Mark: I couldn't even tell if I got ya
Dlive: Wade
Mark: I must've- Oh-
Dlive: Wade, I have the rubbing kit
Wade: Ok
Mark: Y-you're like passed out in the-
Dlive: I got my little kit
Entoan: We got the rubbing kit
Mark: I can't see you!
Wade: He can't find me (laughs)
Mark: Where are you?!
Dlive: Just don't move!
Mark: You're in the shrubbery
Dlive: Don't move and don't make out
Wade: I'm not
Mark: Wait, oh, there you are
Mark: I see ya
Wade: Oh, no I'm not
Mark: H-Hang on, I got ya
(laughter)
Mark: I got ya. (laughs) You-you were really hidden in there. Like, you were way in there
JP: Was he?
Wade: I'd like to think my full head of bushy, beautiful hair
was the reason
Mark: Yeah, yeah sure. Ok
Mark: I'm a-
JP: I did good!
Mark: Wade, uh- Where's the goddamn hook?!
Wade: JP, you shouldn't say that
Wade: as he's walking towards you carrying my body
Entoan: Y-yeah
Mark: Wait, there's no hooks
JP: Uh, I mean, I
Dlive: Wade, are you wiggling?
JP: didn't do anything
Wade: Oh, no. No, I forgot to wiggle
Dlive: Wade!
Entoan: Oh, Wade!
Mark: (laughs)
Dlive: Wade, you idiot!
Wade: That was my bad
Mark: Wade, you idiot
Wade: Yeah
Mark: God, you're still gonna
JP: You wiggle it!
Dlive: How do you not wiggle?
Mark: makin' out. You forgot to wiggle
Dlive: Hey (x2)
Dlive: Hey
Mark: Hang on, wait, hang on
Wade: I think he found a hook
Dlive: Wade, wiggle (x3), no
Mark: There we go
Mark: Hey, wait, who- who's that over there?
(laughter)
JP: No, Wade!
Mark: Who's- Who's over there?
Entoan: Wade
Mark: Hang on. I saw someone
Dlive: No, you saw nothing
Mark: (chainsaw noises)
Mark: Ok, Wade, I'll be nice
Wade: I like how he sounds his own chainsaw
Dlive: Oh
Mark: Hello, hi!
Entoan: Hey! Ok
Mark: (laughs)
Mark: That was a warning, Wade!
Mark: That's what- Hello
Dlive: Oh, no y- (mumbles)
Mark: Hi (giggles)
Dlive: No (x2)
Mark: Aw, c'mon! How that not hit you?!
Dlive: No. I just got- nope
Dlive: Nope (x3)
Mark: You better not be gettin' Wade down
Mark: AH. YOU DARN MAKE OUTTERS
Dlive & Entoan: Wade! (x2)
Mark: YA DARN MAKING OUT KIDS
Entoan: we need to make better-  Jp: AHHHH               Mark: WITH ALL YOUR KISSING!!
Mark: AND ALL YOUR LIP HAVING... your lip doing...
Mark & Entoan: *scream*
Mark: How did that not hit you?
Dlive: (Laughing) Mark: (Screaming)
Jp: I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
Mark: (evil laughing)
Dlive: Let me rub you
Mark: Wait, where'd you go?
Mark: God dammit you damn vanishing kids...  JP: I just saw something so amazing happen right now
Mark: There you go
Dlive: Are you watching us rub?
All: (laughing) + Entoan: Hey
Mark: (grunting sounds), Okay, now...
Mark: you stay here and uh don't kiss anybody
Mark: That's a warning
Mark: don't kiss anybody now everyone else is
off winning I- AHHHHHH
Dlive: I didn't kiss anyone, I promise
Mark: hey hey, i see you there, What are you doing??     JP: NO x4 I DON'T LIKE IT
Mark: Better stay away
Mark: I know it's so tempting to kiss her but don't do it Wade & Dlive: (screaming)
Mark: Y-You Guys really want aggresive...                      Dlive: NO! Please!!! somebody!
Jp: No x4 (scream)
Mark: why do you wanna kiss her? k- Stop kissing!!!
Jp: Ah, we can't stop!
Dlive: KISS HER! KISS HER RIGHT NOW!
Mark: No! God damnit! You friggin kids!
Mark: Cant you let your raging hormones subside for ONE SECOND?!
Mark: Hello! Hahah! You're lucky i went sprinting off in the wrong direction!
Jp: I am SO thankful, right now. Dlive: My masseuse kit is getting a real workout here
Dlive: Oh! I'm sorry!
*Unintelligible*
Dlive: Run! Mark: EHHH!
Others: *Unintelligible* Mark: Alright Okay Alright Okay.
Dlive: My masseuse kit's gone, I lost it
Wade: No! I need masseusing! Others: *Unintelligible... Again.* Mark: No-one needs masseusing
Dlive: Im just gonna do it raw.
Mark: *Laughs hysterically* Wade: I need a raw rub please! Mark: NO!
Mark: THAT MAKES ANGRIEST OF ALL! No raw rubbing!
Wade: Oh yeah raw rubbin'! Mark: No! No no! no! no! JP: Aw yeah all the rubs! Mark: Leave room for jesus!
Mark: This is a celibate area!
Mark: No no! Wade: *Strange gargling noises*
Jp: OH NO! Mark: *More hysterical Mark laughs*
Mark: Hi! Oh man... Wade: I don't think you say peek-a-boo when you're the one getting beat Jp
Entoan: Uh- Its just me right now...
Mark: What're ya doin down there? Jp: I'm not down here I am over up! Wade: *laughter*
Mark: What are ya doin down here? What are you doin in my basement?! Its not a rubbin' basement! Dlive & Wade: Oh, JP!
Dlive: That was the WRONG place to go!
Mark: Hi! Wha- *laughs*
Jp: NO! Mark: Hi! *giggles* Entoan: You NEVER go to the basement!
Mark: Alright, hang on... hang on, wait a minute. *Unintelligibleness happens once again* Jp: How 'bout.. Oh. Well, alright.
Dlive: Okay, so we have a decision here to make guys. Jp: I have a-  Wade: He's in the basement there's  no decision. Entoan: I believe I remember JP
just running out on us.
Mark: Yeah. Yeah. *talking over a bunch of much louder talking* you should leave 'em! You should really leave 'em!
Jp: *lots of screaming*
Dlive: JP! How did you do that?!
Mark: Hi again! Welcome to the party! *lots of talking thats all jumbled* JP: I wont- I wont have another kiss again!
Mark: It seems like YOU... forgot that you needed to stay on here.
Mark: This is for your own good buddy.
Dlive: Jp! Struggle! Struggle! Mark: Struggle! Struggle!
Mark: I like it when I see 'em struggle! Go! Struggle!
Wade: He's sick. He's the kinda sicko that would! mark: That's me! That's me alright!
Well, I'll leave ya.
You look like you're havin' fun. So, have a good one! Good down there? Ya need some juice?
How in the fu...?! Entoan: Oh shi...! Dlive: JP! Entoan: Hey! Mark: Hahahahaha! Entoan: Trade me! Mark: Trade? I'll take a trade.
I'm okay with that. Dlive: Run outta here!
Jp: But I wanna help Entoan, he just risked his life!
Mark: Okay, is there- Are you down here again?!
Dlive: Jp, you're about to get the rub of your life.
Jp: Oh yay-uh! Mark: Where did you go? Wade: There's some makeout rubbing going on monster
Mark: Where?! Where is that  makeout rubbin'?! Better not be! (x2)
Entoan: I need...I need some rubbin right now! Mark: Wheres all this rubbin' happenin'?!
Jp: -we can do that... Mark: How did you get down here, anyway? Entoan: I went right behind you.
Mark: Oh okay. I gotcha. Hello! Hi! *Mr. Wade-screams-a-lot* Who wants some makeout rubs?!
RAAAAH! Awwh, man! How did that miss?!
All right. Okay. Its- WHAT?! HOW?! WHAT THE HELL?!
Jp: Uh, parkour. Dlive: You should have waited! Mark: RAH! Jp: RUN! RUN THE DOOR IS OPEN!
Mark: Nope nope nope. JP: Where is it?! Wheres the door?!
Mark: Oh-ohohoh.. You guys... You silly guys. Dlive: Jp let me rub you (x2)
Hey buddy. Hows it goin?
Dlive: Let me rub you Entoan: I really like your basement don't put me on that
*Lots of talking* Dlive: Jp don't worry about it he doesn't see the rubbing
JP: He doesn't realize we are rubbing each other right now.
All right! Done bein' rubbed! I'm back up! Mark: How much rubbin' is happening? JP: A lot.
Entoan: *grunts* Mark: Uh-huh. Dlive: Run to the door! The door is open!
Mark: HIYAAAAAAAAAAAAAhhh! *chuckles* Dlive: I hear somebody!
Run! Hey! Hey! Right here!
Mark: Damnit!
Dlive: Yes! Run please! Mark: What're ya doin?(x3) Dlive: Run as fast as you can!
Dlive: AHHHHHH! Woo-hoo-hoo! Mark: Aw man! That was so close!
That's so close! Dlive: The door is open!!! The OTHER door is open! Why are you running around?! Run! The door is OpeeeeNNN!
JP:I believe! Entoan: Does anyone know where the OTHER door is...? *lots of chatter*
Wade:Its a pretty good rub.
Dlive: Woah. Wade: Its a really good rub. Mark: *grunting* May-may-maybe I should be more open-minded
To this new age rubbing. Wade: Oh you wanna join in?
Its just my old ways you know? I'm settin my ways.
I didn't rub until I was 22, y'know. Wade: Really? Dlive: i saw you
I was a late rubber, y'know. Dlive: Come to the other door
Entoan: Yeah come to the other door. Jp: Yeah, I can- Mark: Yeah? Yeah? Ya think so?
You'd welcome me in the rub party? *Lots of screaming* Haha.. Hahahahaha!
Dlive: I'm sorry wade!
Mark: Who'd I get? Dlive: "Who'd I get?!" Hahahaha! Mark: Who did I get?! (x2) Dlive: I'm sorry wade. Sorry- hahahaha.
Mark: I know. I know Wade. I know.
JP: It couldn't- Wade: Guys could you... Jp: You guys should have rubbed a lil' faster.
Mark: Yeah I mean really what were you thinking?
Hey, this is the good ol' hook! This is the hook I used before!
Alright Wade. Hi! hahaha!
Howzit goin'?! Ah dicks. Oh no.
Dlive: Wade! Wade! Run! Run! Run!
Jp: We had it!
Wade: NOOO! Mark: *laughter* Are ya running for it?! YA RUNNIN FOR IT?!
HUH?! Wade: Oh hi mark. Mark: Whats up?
Oh NO! (x2) AHHAHAHA! Jp: WADE ARE YOU KIDDING ME
Awww! I cant get you! I cant get you! Wade: I'm crawling away!
Dlive: Wade are you CRAWLING?! Entoan: OKAY I'm going!
Mark: Awwww! EHHHHHHHHH! Entoan: One last rub session! Dlive: No! Mark: Aw dammit. I was completely
inaccurate with all that chainsaw
sprinting. It wasn't good. It wasn't good times.
Jp: Wade is still crawling backwards for me
Wade: How am I gonna win?! I have no left leg left...
Dlive: Wade, you just crawled into a fire, on my screen! JP: I know! Now hes off the world for me! Mark: *Chuckles*
That's what I get for bein' nice.
I'm a kind killer. Dlive: Hey at least you let the rubbing happen
Yeah... I came around to the rubbin! The rubbin' won me over in the end.
*Couldn't make it out. Sorry viewers.*